today we've traveled halfway across the
country with abs master smith Jay
neelson America is home to some of the
world's top bladesmiths and the forge I
chose is where thousands have gotten
their start we're heading to the
world-renowned bill Maran School of blad
smithing located in Texarcana
Texas home of the oldest blad smithing
School in the world Bill Moran is a
legend he not only founded the school
and the American blad Society but he
also revived the Lost Art of Damascus
now their top Smiths will compete to
represent this shop and me for their
chance at becoming a fortune and fire
Champion guys congratulations on making
it through the first round it means the
two of you are still in this tournament
and in the running for $20,000 going to
yourselves and an extra $10,000 that
could be coming back here to the bill
Moran School of blades smithing now as
you probably noticed this competition
has been all about the ABS theme and we
figured we'd keep that going into this
next round where we're sending you back
to your home forges to build this
ABS master smith quillian
dagger but guys you're so talented we
figured why not supersize this a little
bit and have you build a shortsword
version of the dagger so good luck
gentlemen we'll see you back at our
Forge in 4 days good luck man we're at
my home Forge right now we're in Plano
Texas I got to bring a win home for the
Lone Star
State let's get rocking and
rolling
everything look to be gone pretty solid
time to get my blade looking like a
knife hell yeah that's looking good so I
couldn't be more pleased with how today
went got a sore man yesterday on day
three got my blade heat
treated I just got to get everything fit
up and start shaping my handle material
it's not going to be the best flute
I myself am a perfectionist especially
with my craft and what I do with my work
I'm real OCD and I like to nitpick my
stuff and just make it as good as I can
make it when fitting up the
handle the whole build was super
challenging but I'm grateful to be a
part of this competition and I'm super
proud to represent the bill Moran School
of blades smithing holy guys I got that
done I got that done that looks so
freaking cool
badass it's the morning of day one I'm
ready to get started on this quillian
shortsword got a good squish on it it's
looking pretty good to me so
far so I have enough material to work
the tang and work my tip and it came out
phenomenal so far so good hope that this
quench works
out if this thing ends up cracking I'm
out of the
competition
okay this blades quenched I'm happy
about
that and oh my goodness it's hard I'm
like
yes both my guard and my pommel they are
made out of mild
steel and that will there you go the
weapon is put together peened on looks
good so I get to play with it a little
bit I think we'll definitely
cut all right gentlemen the time has
come we've got to find out which one of
you is moving forward in the next leg of
the tournament staying in contention for
that $20,000 check for yourselves an
additional $10,000 that could go back to
Don and the bill Maran School of blad
smithing and to do that we've got to put
your blades through a series of tests
and for those tests I'm going to hand
you over to
Jay well blad SMI your big boy versions
of the master smith quillian dagger look
really nice but looking good is one
thing functionality is more important so
I'm going to take both of your short
swords and do a series of thrusts and
chops on this ballistics dummy
rig Chris you're up first you ready to
go it's ready as I'll ever
be
[Applause]
just kick those
sh who needs a
sword
all right Chris nice job very well
balanced with the fluting you have on
this handle it was a good grip Shield
wanted to put a bit of a fight but we
made it through um the only thing I have
to say negative is the alignment cuz I'm
holding the handle vertically and you
can see that blade curves off to one
side but all in all everything's Sharp
everything is tight nice job thank
you all right Jake you ready to go I'm
ready
all right Jake nice job everything's
still in alignment nothing wrong with
the edge nothing chipped out or anything
everything's tight I like the
counterbalance you put in here with the
RW iron the fluting on here give me a
good grip so overall very nice job
thank all right blad Smith now we know
your blades are functional next we're
going to see how strong they are and how
well they hold up in our strength
test Chris you up first again you ready
yes sir all right let's do
it
[Music]
all right Chris real nice good grip able
to hold on no problem you do have some
glinting so you can hear that yes sir
that's the worst one right there so you
do have some Edge
damage but obviously it was still sharp
enough to cut through those bags um
again that blade being kicked off throws
up the thrusting overall though nice job
thank
you Jake ready again let's do
it
[Music]
a
all right Jake nice job cut deeply into
the steel there is some glinting he got
a little bit of a roll aside from that
everything is still
straight good job thank you well
gentlemen this is it we started this
competition back in Tex Arcana with you
guys putting together Damascus blades
and you went above and beyond but only
one one of you can come out on top of
the Texas Arcana leg of this tournament
and move forward into the final leg
fighting against three other Smiths we
pick up across
America and the winner of this leg who
will be representing the bill Moran
School of blades smithing and Jay neelon
is Jake
congratulations uh Chris unfortunately
your blade did not make the cut I'm
going to have to ask you to please step
off the forge
floor thank you man all in all I'm just
happy with how my blade performed I
completely agree with his decision to
vote me
off Jake congratulations that makes you
the winner of the Tex Arcana leg of this
tournament you're moving forward into
the final leg still fighting for that
$20,000 to go in your pocket and $10,000
in Gears and supplies to go back to Don
in the bill Moran School of blad
smithing I don't even know how to feel
this is so cool it was anyone's game it
was such a close fight from the
beginning at Tex Arcana to here Chris
has been an awesome competitor but I
took home the victory today and I don't
even know what to do like it's pretty
awesome congratulations yes sir very
very well done pleasure man I'll be
representing the billan school of blad
smithing in the next leg of this
Challenge and I'm super excited so let's
get after
it